An important reason why
conditional probabilities are
very useful is that they allow
us to divide and conquer.
They allow us to split
complicated probability modes
into simpler submodels
that we can then
analyze one at a time.
Let me remind you of the Total
Probability Theorem that has
his particular flavor.
We divide our sample space into
three disjoint events--
A1, A2, and A3.
And these events form a
partition of the sample space,
that is, they exhaust
all possibilities.
They correspond to three
alternative scenarios, one of
which is going to occur.
And then we may be interested
in a certain event B. That
event B may occur under
either scenario.
And the Total Probability
Theorem tells us that we can
calculate the probability of
event B by considering the
probability that it occurs under
any given scenario and
weigh those probabilities
according to the probabilities
of the different scenarios.
Now, let us bring random
variables into the picture.
Let us fix a particular
value--
little x--
and let the event B be the event
that the random variable
takes on this particular
value.
Let us now translate the
Total Probability
Theorem to this situation.
First, the picture will look
slightly different.
Our event B has been replaced
by the particular event that
we're now considering.
Now, what is this probability?
The probability that event B
occurs, having fixed the
particular choice of little x,
is the value of PMF at that
particular x.
How about this probability
here?
This is the probability that the
random variable, capital
X, takes on the value
little x--
that's what a PMF is--
but in the conditional
universe.
So we're dealing with
a conditional PMF.
And so on with the
other terms.
So this equation here is just
the usual Total Probability
Theorem but translated
into PMF notation.
Now this version of the Total
Probability Theorem, of
course, is true for all
values of little x.
This means that we can now
multiply both sides of this
equation by x and them
sum over all
possibles choices of x.
We recognize that here we have
the expected value of the
random variable X.
Now, we do the same thing
to the right hand side.
We multiply by x.
And then we sum over all
possible values of x.
This is going to be
the first term.
And then we will have
similar terms.
Now, what do we have here?
This expression is just the
conditional expectation of the
random variable X under
the scenario that
event A1 has occurred.
So what we have established is
this particular formula, which
is called the Total Expectation
Theorem.
It tells us that the expected
value of a random variable can
be calculated by considering
different scenarios.
Finding the expected value under
each of the possible
scenarios and weigh them.
Weigh the scenarios according
to their respective
probabilities.
The picture is like this.
Under each scenario, the
random variable X has a
certain conditional
expectation.
We take all these
into account.
We weigh them according
to their corresponding
probabilities.
And we add them up to find
the expected value of X.
So we can divide and conquer.
We can replace a possibly
complicated calculation of an
expected value by hopefully
simpler calculations under
each one of possible
scenarios.
Let me illustrate the idea
by a simple example.
Let us consider this PMF, and
let us try to calculate the
expected value of the associated
random variable.
One way to divide and conquer
is to define an event, A1,
which is that our random
variable takes values in this
set, and another event, A2,
which is that the random
variable takes values
in that set.
Let us now apply the Total
Expectations Theorem.
Let us calculate all the terms
that are required.
First, we find the
probabilities of
the different scenarios.
The probability of event
A1 is 1/9 plus 1/9 plus
1/9 which is 1/3.
And the probability of event
A2 is 2/9 plus 2/9 plus 2/9
which adds up to 2/3.
How about conditional
expectations?
In a universe where event A1 one
has occurred, only these
three values are possible.
They had equal probabilities,
so in the conditional model,
they will also have equal
probabilities.
So we will have a uniform
distribution over
the set .
By symmetry, the expected
value is going
to be in the middle.
So this expected value
is equal to 1.
And by a similar argument, the
expected value of X under the
second scenario is going to be
the midpoint of this range,
which is equal to 7.
And now we can apply the Total
Probability Theorem and write
that the expected value of X is
equal to the probability of
the first scenario times the
expected value under the first
scenario plus the probability
of the second scenario times
the expected value under
the second scenario.
In this case, by breaking down
the problem in these two
subcases, the calculations
that were required were
somewhat simpler than if you
were to proceed directly.
Of course, this is a rather
simple example.
But as we go on with this
course, we will apply the
Total Probability Theorem in
much more interesting and
complicated situations.